welcome my fine viewers to episode
number two of stuckman suggests you may
remember the last time I suggested
Catherine reitman to you and a lot of
people have become big fans of her and
now I have a new person to suggest to
you it's a female and she specializes in
reviewing scary films so isn't that cool
because I love scary movies I love scary
movie so much oh man I love scary movies
okay her name is Jill Hill and her
channel is all about scary films she
reviews horror films anything with a
supernatural twist like aliens or
monsters and creatures you know things
like that and I stumbled across her
channel because she commented on my
wicker man review I was like oh I don't
recognize that name so I went to a
channel she already has her foot in the
door she's got about eleven hundred
subscribers or so looking to make the
1986 version of the fly amazing is Jeff
Goldblum because of course Jeff Goldblum
is a very strange human being to begin
with and so it's sort of believable that
his pot fly he talks and looks around
with the big eyes that's sort of what
makes a movie that the special effects
thing I look for in anyone's videos is
does the love of their subject shine
through the videos can you tell that
person just loves and adores what
they're talking about can you tell that
that person has a passion for what he or
she is talking about in my word her
channel
screams personal admiration and love for
scary films and I love that I love that
you can feel her passion through her
reviews also they're very well edited
and that's something I really pay
attention to because you know some
people just stand there and let just
kind of like they're like I really like
YouTube videos and like I want to thank
everyone for watching my spit you know
what I mean videos are edited well and
you can really just feel that she has a
love for what she's talking about she's
also a horror writer and so she's an
aspiring writer which is really cool
because I am as well and I'm an aspiring
filmmaker so is she she's into all that
kind of stuff so I'd be looking for a
good channel with entertaining videos
brought to you by a nice girl who likes
scary movies and is going to tell you
what is good check Jill kill
because she's not gonna treat horror
films like the average critic with Lego
it's a horror movie it's dumb no she's
gonna judge horror films like a fan of
wood you know she's gonna be able to
sift out the good ones from the bad and
not just bash on all of them like they
do
so check out Jill kill if you can and
yeah so to stuckman suggest and I'll
hopefully find someone else cool to talk
to you about in the future